still shocked by the scale of the
tragedy South Korea is now a nation in
mourning
Memorial altars have been set up in
cities across the country as people line
up quietly and patiently to pay their
respects
I feel terrible that these young people
have fallen without having blossomed
because of the faults of us in the older
Generations
is the father of a child it hurts my
heart so much
if there is a festival like this again I
believe things will be done
appropriately so something like this is
not repeated among those grieving a
grandfather who lost two grandchildren
in the tragedy
they both wins
and I could get in touch with them
initially now their bodies are lying in
hospital I feel so sorry as a
grandfather for not being able to do
anything
also paying his respects the president
Yun sukyol who has promised to review
crowd control measures at future events
there are strict rules and guidelines
for organized Gatherings such as rallies
and protests but not for unofficial
street festivals as South Korea begins
this period of mourning there is a sense
of disbelief that this tragedy could
have happened in a society renowned for
self-control and following the rules and
why it seems nobody anticipated the
crush of people that gathered with such
deadly consequences
at a briefing from the government's
Emergency Response Team reporters
repeatedly asked why more police were
not on duty to handle crowd control
instead of tackling crime
when it comes to public Gatherings the
police have been focusing on crime
prevention and illegal Crackdown rather
than on the spot control
the government has also announced
financial support to help families pay
for the many funerals that will take
place in the coming days as well as
medical expenses for the scores who were
injured once the morning period is over
there will likely be fundamental changes
in the way all future public Gatherings
are controlled but it has taken this
Halloween tragedy for that to happen Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Seoul